men
not immigrants
are the problem
across time space
geography culture
men have consistently and overwhelmingly perpetuated violence against women
white American men also unalive women all the time
they are actually most consistently in this country
the mass unalivers and they do this to women because they're women
because they don't like how you looked at them
or you didn't look at them
or how you dressed or how you failed to acquiesce to their demands
or you didn't give them your attention or your time
do this to women because they're women
it's a form of misogyny
they are using violence
and just the general threat of violence
to ensure that they can try to maintain control over women
focusing that narrative on that this individual was an undocumented immigrant
only fuels that misogyny because every time this stuff happens
whether it's mass on a living
or it's a situation like this
we talk about everything else
except for the problem that is right in front of us
it's men
we have a profound problem with violence against women
that is specifically perpetuated by men
in order to address that we need to name it